every other year we go through the same
ritual lime prices spike and then people
wonder why they're paying fifty cents of
lime instead of thirty cents a line then
we come up with theories our theories
are about the weather there's bad
weather that causes Lyme crops to fail
or we talk about the lime light which is
slowly moving its way up from Brazil
through Central America these are all
very real problems but they aren't the
problem the reason we have lime price
spikes in America is because we have
chosen to get all of our lines now when
I say all of our lives I mean that
ninety seven percent of the limes that
we drink in America come from one place
a few states in Mexico we should grow
lines in America but then an actual act
of God happened in 1992 Hurricane Andrew
laid waste to a huge part of southern
Florida exactly those parts of the
country where we grew lon they tried to
regrow then there was a lime light again
a real problem but that wasn't the final
problem what happened in that same
decade we closed the North American Free
Trade Agreement it was cheaper to grow
limes in Mexico the lime crop in the
u.s. never recovered from that we draw a
grapefruit here we grow oranges here we
do not grow limes in America this is
what free trade does it seeks out the
place where production costs are the
lowest and then moves production to that
place good news cheap limes usually the
problem with centering all of our line
production in one place is that it
leaves us completely open to whatever
happens in that one place the market
doesn't care about risk the market cares
about price and what we the tequila
drinkers of America have decided is that
we're okay with these price fluctuations
if we weren't okay then we would
diversify our sources of production
we're not doing that we're making this
choice so good news America drink up
limes are cheap again for now